you could feel the sweat it was totally
different than Ferguson you could feel
your parents shaking it was like a pin
drop thing I remember the sound of guns
I remember the helicopters which back
then sounded different i could smell the
smoke and you could anyway did you ever
think that 50 years later no no actually
no that we would still be happy
absolutely not it's just absolutely
appalling you know I'm too many
different levels here well yes so
Ferguson is burning you've seen the
images chaos erupted in the Missouri
town after a grand jury declined to
indict a white police officer for
fatally shooting an unarmed black
teenager businesses were looted police
cars burned a dozen buildings went up in
flames Bloomberg News reporter to lose
ol Arun appiah joins us live now from
the streets of Ferguson so to lose you
were there described to us the chaos you
saw unfold last night what was your
experience yes it was very similar to
how Tom described in 1960s there was
smoke there was fires there were
gunshots in the air a couple police cars
were burned down several businesses were
broken into and there was generally a
sense of chaos on the street there have
been these nightly process for more than
three months but last night was unlike
any previous night here in Ferguson
there was you know significant damage
done all across the across the city
including as you mentioned about a dozen
buildings that were burned all the way
to the ground to lose President Obama
came out about two hours after the
indictment to speak to the country did
his comments were they heard by the
people on the street do you have any a
sense of whether they did anything to
mollify the situation well honestly the
situation on the ground had already
changed by the time the president began
speaking as soon as the announcement was
was the decision was announced by the
the prosecutor people had taken to the
streets some of the looting had already
begun some businesses had already been
attacked and I don't think people were
listening to the president at that point
Oh nicely described as you say they were
not listening the president they were
looking at the immediacy there
what is the catalyst to see a
continuance of this violence in protest
into tonight and into the coming weekend
well people have been have been waiting
for this decision for several months in
that and what we saw was kind of an out
spilling of emotion that has been pent
up so I get the sense that there will be
continued demonstrations people will
continue to take to the streets and
there will actually be now more National
Guardsmen being brought out so we have a
potential for more significant classes
between the police and the activists
what does it look like right now well
there are still businesses that are the
fires are being trying to be put out and
they're still fires at several
businesses a lot of people have cleared
the streets but there are already calls
for 7am demonstrations here at the
courthouse in Clayton Missouri where the
grand jury met so it looks like people
are gearing up to come out to the
streets once again what do you think
we're going to see today in terms of
looting now we're going to be in the
light of day where people could be
arrested how do you compare that to what
we saw last night the rage the fury at
midnight here we're going to wake up at
9am people will be back in the streets
do you predict it'll be more peaceful a
la Chicago New York Houston Atlanta oh
well that's likely especially given that
the governor has called on more national
guardsmen to show up we're likely to see
more of a heavy heavy police presence
guarding some of these businesses in the
light of day but no one knows what's
going to happen one night falls it's
pretty cold but that did not stop people
from coming out last night and it's
likely that people will continue to come
out until until everything settles down
to lose what happens now to Darren
Wilson obviously he is very unlikely to
walk the streets of Ferguson ever again
we've heard he's likely to resign from
the forest we have heard he had time to
get married in the last month what
happens to him now yes he is likely that
he will not return to the force we also
have to remember that he's still kind of
a subject of an ongoing federal
investigation as well as the police
department could be hit with a civil
civil lawsuit over
things played out back in August so
we're unlikely to see him return to the
Ferguson as a police officer people are
still going over his testimony and he
likely will be maybe doing interviews
and but we don't plan to see him return
as a police officer is brought about but
what about his personal safety well for
the most part he has not been very
visible in Ferguson so we probably
expect him to continue to remain in
hiding he may do an interview on
television but I don't expect to see him
out and about in the community it's
likely that he will relocate in position
himself far away from from these
protests